health secretary sergey javid is with us
do you remember where you were when it
happened yes i do i'll never forget i
was working on the trading floor in the
city
and uh
one thing i won't forget is that we had
a live sort of phone connection at all
times with our trading floor in the
world trade center and we could hear the
sounds and the noises coming live down
the line and you know i'd never forget
that no one could did all your
colleagues get out yes they did thank
well
almost all of them sadly some did not um
20th anniversary can't believe it really
can we um i want to talk to you about um
health and social care in just a second
but given that we're talking about that
can i ask you about afghanistan the
taliban's appointed a caretaker
government one of the people the
interior minister is on the fbi's most
wanted are they people that we can do
business with
well i would say in the last 24 hours i
haven't had much time to look at the
afghanistan caretaker government
but i think that as a general
point that
now the afghanistan clearly seem to be
in charge
that we need to keep under review how we
work with them but is also going to be
in our long-term interest to make sure
that we can continue to help people in
afghanistan especially those people that
we have commitments to that are still
trying to leave we can work with the
terrorist government though can we no
i'm not saying we should recognize the
government prime minister's been very
clear about this that if we eventually
formally recognize a government then
there's certain things that we will be
looking for not just in behavior but how
they also
deal with
other governments as well and some of
the plans that they make but what we
should always be doing is looking to
find ways to help those people that
still need our support in afghanistan
something that you're very comfortable
talking about of course this morning is
health and social care
um i read in the papers it's the highest
taxes since
the second world war
um you sure you're in the right party
yes i'm sure of that i think what we've
announced in the last 24 hours actually
is a very conservative thing to do we
are committed as a party to the nhs i
want the nhs to be there for everyone a
world-class health service free at the
point of views paid through general
taxation i as a health secretary when i
came into this job a couple of months
ago and i was told that the waiting list
already at 5.5 million because of the
global pandemic and the pressures that's
created could go to as high as 13
million in three years time i can't
tolerate that i can't accept that so
something had to be done and i think the
british public understand that similarly
with adult social care i think the fact
that some people who have this risk of
catastrophic cares uh cost your care of
cost
that that is not acceptable where you
have some one in seven people that have
to pay over a hundred thousand pounds
for their care i think it's a very
conservative thing to do to give people
that confidence that to know that their
lifetime cost of care can be capped for
them the plan is to cap that at 86 000
pounds i think it's the right thing to
do and to do it properly and sustainably
i don't like raising taxes i want taxes
to be as low as they possibly can be but
i think people understand if we want the
nhs to be there for us always doing its
job then
we've got to properly fund that and the
same applies to adult social care this
is going to be enough money or will we
be potentially looking at more tax rises
no i think this is enough money i mean
this is a it's a very large amount of
money it's around 12 billion pounds a
year so over the three year next three
years 36 billion pounds
it's around 16 billion of that directly
to the nhs that will pay for things like
9 million more checks scans and
treatments helping to tackle that
waiting list it's also over 5 billion
pounds more for the adult social care
system not just paying for that that cap
but also a more generous means-tested
system more support for the workforce
these are exactly the kind of changes we
need to make but only one in only a
pound in every six is going to go to
social care and that in a couple of
years time almost all of it is going to
go to the nhs um can you guarantee that
the money will go to social care in the
in the fullness of time
yes the money that we've planned because
damian green who you know is a former
cabinet office minister saying
the 5.4 billion will go to social care
that's uh that that's that's clearly set
out in our plans and in fact we're
already working yeah that's yes it will
go
you've made lots of promises in your
manifesto and you've broken those well
i'm very happy to talk about that and
the prime minister has been very clear
on that when questioned yesterday so he
was asked for example around the promise
not to raise uh national insurance and
other tax rates and you know what we
could have done the options were we
could have just doggedly stuck to that
and said you know
we know there's been a global pandemic
we know that the nhs and social care
facing their biggest challenges in their
lifetime but you know what we've got a
promise on on taxes and we're not going
to touch them and therefore people will
just have to live with this risk and and
that's not that's not the what a
responsible government would do the job
of a responsible government we're going
to be listening to challenges yeah my
viewers this morning will say yeah but
you've broken two election promises
within two years and i think your
viewers will also see
through their own regions the areas that
they live the pressures that are on the
nhs they can see the rise in the waiting
list has already taken place to 5.5
million and just imagine if it was going
to go to 13 million if it had been
business as usual that's what was that's
what's likely to have happened a 13
million waiting list that could have
been one person in every family on the
waiting list i'm the health secretary
health and social care sector i can't
have that and i don't think your viewers
want that and so it has to be paid for
when you're going to pay for that you
can't then just say we're going to
borrow it as some people suggested
yesterday why don't you just borrow it
because that's just really putting off
the problem and moving it to the next
generation it's just a future tax rise
for our young people today we've got to
confront it and that means everyone
paying into it together i think the way
the chancellor has come up with the
money which is mainly through this
increase in national insurance their
health and social care levy and ring
fenced it and guaranteed that it will
always in the future go to health and
social care i think that's the right way
to do it and it's a very progressive way
to do it are you saying that the nhs
wasn't in trouble before coburn
the nhs of course it's always you know
it's it's the
biggest no it's the biggest universal
health service in the world it's always
had challenges for as long as i can
remember but i think the difference now
is that with the global pandemic and
what that's unleashed it's the biggest
challenge in its in living memory i
think it's fair to say that and i'm full
of nothing but praise for everyone that
works in the nhs and how they have
handled uh this pandemic and they also
deserve this support making sure that
they've got the equipment that they need
the ppe they need the new technology
that they need and that we continue to
invest so for example one of the things
i'll be doing with this money is
creating a lot more of what i call
surgical hubs because if i look at that
waiting list a lot of the waiting is for
treatments like it might be like a hip
replacement a cataract surgery and if we
can create more of these dedicated hubs
we can offer more of these treatments
you know come rain or shine every day
they're available while the nhs gets on
with other work as well so you say are
you saying that this money will
guarantee to clear the backlog
no no responsible health secretary can
make that kind of guarantee
enough money
by saying it was enough money because we
know because we've worked with the nhs
very closely as you would imagine and we
have thought carefully about the money
that's needed but we've also had to make
some assumptions and on things that no
one can tell you what's actually going
to happen so with covid the pathway of
cobit no one in the world knows what
happens next with kobit so i have to
make assumptions about for example how
much testing we need to do how much we
will spend on vaccines and on ppe we've
also had to make assumptions about the
the the amount of um the capacity in the
nhs and how how we can increase that so
what we've worked out with the nhs for
example is that the nhs will be able to
operate at a hundred and ten percent of
uh its normal capacity a year so it can
get through a lot more uh treatments and
checks and scans uh than before so i'm
going to be working quite hand in hand
really closely with the new chief
executive of the nhs and making sure
that together we're doing everything we
can what i can be absolutely certain of
is that this will massively reduce the
waiting list from where it would
otherwise have been it will hugely
tackle it and that's what i think your
viewers would expect me to do
vaccinations let's talk about that given
that we're talking about uh covid where
are we with the booster jabs because
depends who you're talking to as to
whether or not they're a good idea
we've received interim advice on
boosters and that was a few weeks ago
when i published it and that was clear
that there should be some kind of a
booster program so i'm very confident
there will be a booster program but in
terms well
in terms of who actually gets it and
when we're waiting for final advice
which could come across in certainly in
the next few days from the jcvi and i
need to see that advice because they
rightly are looking at studies that
they've done
to look at what should be
it should we be mixing vaccines for
example should people get the same
vaccine they're also looking at whether
it makes sense to co-administer it for
everyone with a flu jab as well so that
work is almost done and based on the the
the timeline that they've given us i am
confident that we can start the booster
program this month you don't always take
the advice of the jcvi though do you um
i have then yes and including
yes i thought you were going to say that
and i've taken their advice because what
was their advice their advice was that
they've looked at this
and they are only by statute able to
look at the the health side of
vaccination they're not able to look at
wider issues when it comes to children
such as
impact on their education schooling and
things like that and they've said that
they recommended to me their advice was
that you should ask these the chief
medical officers of the uk collectively
for their opinion because they don't
feel qualified to talk about issues that
are not in their mandate i've taken
their advice okay so are 12 to 15 year
olds going to have jobs i don't know i
haven't got the advice from these people
medical officers um i i would expect i i
i couldn't put a timeline on them i
think that would have been unfair
because they've got to come to their own
judgment
independently they've had kids they've
gone back to school well the chief
medical officers have had about four
days so
of course as we both know have had
significantly longer than that you would
have thought that you'd be able to
dovetail that back into kids going back
to school the chief medical officers is
who i'm waiting for uh now and
i want to give them the breathing space
it's their independent view and and
that's exactly what it should be but i i
i i would expect to hit from them the
next few days how would you feel about
12 to 15 year olds of yours having jabs
i don't think it's appropriate for me to
pass a judgment because i'm waiting for
an independent view do you think that 12
to 15 year olds should be able to
overrule their parents on whether or not
they should have jobs i think we should
follow the same rules that we've had in
this country under successive
governments for for decades which is
that
you first would try to seek the consent
of parents for parents we're going to
ask all parents for consent and uh in
most cases but what if they don't give
it as micro if they don't give consent
and children still want their exactly so
if there's a difference of opinion
between the child
and the parent
then we have a specialist that let's say
that work in this area this school's
vaccination service they would usually
literally sit down with the parent and
the child and try to reach some kind of
consensus if ultimately that doesn't
work
as long as we believe that the child is
competent enough to make this decision
then the child's will will prevail how
do you feel about an october fire break
if necessary would you support it um
what do you mean by that i mean by uh by
that potentially
fire break lock down whatever you want
to call it in order to in in some form
or another in order to try to stop the
virus um getting legs again going into
the winter well i don't think that uh
that's something we need to consider i
didn't think that last year look look it
is true that no one knows the future
pathway of this uh
of this i'm guessing you'd support it so
i'm not i'm not i haven't even thought
about that as a as an option at this
point because i think
well no as a decisions that we've made
in the last uh few weeks and certainly
in the time i've been health secretary i
think they've turned out to be the right
decisions uh we've shown that you're
being chill to eat out to help at this
time last year
well
i wasn't in government this time last
year so you can get a minister in the
the you know was making whatever
decision
i can talk about the decisions that have
been made since i've been in government
and especially or especially around it
means that it won't we won't have
another way if you're going to support a
fire break aren't you obviously well
i've told you i think that what we are
the policies that we followed uh so far
they're based on the the best
information the best evidence that we
can get we listen to our experts
of course as anyone would expect and so
when we made the recent decision to
start opening up the country to move the
social distancing restrictions for
example and other rules that i think
that's turned out to be exactly the
right decision and it's not risk-free
when you make these decisions none of
them are risk-free no one knows exactly
what's going on nobody wants to be in
your shoes that's obviously the ca i
mean you're doing an incredible job
given the challenges that you're facing
but nevertheless very much well it's
true it's true
you exactly but you better bottle it
because i don't think i'm not sure how
often it's going to come along but
people at home will want to know whether
if when it's october half term
potentially it that could be two weeks
for kids as a result of uh trying to
stop um another wave third fourth fifth
wave whatever we're counting uh our best
defense against another wave or mircobed
ever taking off again is the vaccine
wall of defense that's been hugely
successful we've got 80 percent of
adults now that are double vaccinated
and uh we
you would continue to build in that
program we've just talked about boosters
for example as well oh last week i also
announced
a third dose for those that are
immunosuppressed because again we're
always looking at the evidence to see
what more we can do the vaccines are
working yes there are still infections
of course there's still all that's true
around the world but the number of
people going into hospital and certainly
those dying is mercifully low and that's
because of the vaccines we're out of
time but we're just about to head to um
calais to our reporter on the boat uh 54
million pounds is how much we want to
give to the french are we getting value
for money from them when it comes to
well
i think i think it's
when i was home secretary i was working
with the french on the on the same issue
and uh they you know in my experience is
that it's really good to cooperate look
this is a joint problem between the
french and the british and uh
and i think it makes absolute sense to
to work together to share intelligence
and see what you can do okay it's good
to talk to you i have to let you go it's
great to see you thank you very much